VERY MUCH IN SARAH'S WORDS SO
CRUCIAL, SHE SAYS FURTHER AND
FURTHER IN BECAUSE THAT STILL
APPEARS TO BE VERY MUCH THE
FOCUS.
PUTIN WANTS MORE AND MORE OF
UKRAINE, NOT SCALING BACK,
SCALING UP, AND THIS COMES AS
UKRAINIAN FORCES ARE PUSHING
BACK RUSSIAN FORCES IN A CRUCIAL
VILLAGE IN SOUTHERN UKRAINE, A
PLACE, FRANKLY UNDER RUSSIAN
CONTROL FOR WEEKS.
NICK PAYTON WALSH IS "OUTFRONT"
ON THE GROUND WITH MORE.
>> Reporter: BRACING UNDER THE
TREELINE, CHANGING THEIR PATH
EVERY TIME, WITH RUSSIAN TROOPS
OFTEN JUST METERS AWAY, THIS IS
THE FIGHT FOR UKRAINE'S MOST
IMPORTANT RIVERBANK AND THIS IS
THE PLACE WHERE MOSCOW'S BRUTAL
ADVANCE IS BEEN STOPPED.
HELD BY RUSSIAN TROOPS FOR
WEEKS, BUT NOW, THE RUSSIANS
SHELL WHERE THEY ONCE HID AND
PROBE THE OUTSKIRTS DAILY.
VLADIMIR AND HIS MEN HAVE BEEN
ALERT SINCE 4:00 A.M., FEARING A
RUSSIAN ATTACK AND MORE OF THE
CLUSTER BOMBS THEY SAY TORE DOWN
THIS TREE.
TWO KILOMETERS AWAY IN THAT
DIRECTION HE SAYS AND -- SO
OCCASIONALLY RUSSIA GETS
SCOUTING GROUPS TO SORT OF PROBE
THE DEFENSES BUT SO FAR THEY'VE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN FIGHTING
THEM.
FRESH FLOWERS LAID THE MONUMENT
TO THE LAST WAR'S DEAD, BUT
BROKEN GLASS HERE WHERE THIS
WAR'S LIVING SHELTER.
FACES THAT SEEM BEYOND CARING
WHO WAS IN CONTROL.
AND DUST THAT MAKES YOU WONDER
WHO WOULD COME BACK IF IT EVER
GETS NORMAL AGAIN.
IN THESE ENDLESS IDYLIC
VILLAGES, IT BENDS BELIEF TO SEE
THE QUIET LIFE FORCED
UNDERGROUND LIKE THIS.
SAYING THAT THE ROCKET LANDED
DURING LUNCHTIME AND THERE WAS
NOBODY IN THERE.
40, 50 PEOPLE HAVE BEEN AT ONE
POINT.
YOU SEE THAT --
>> BUT IT IS NOT AN EASY JOB,
TAKING BACK THESE VILLAGES.
LOYALTIES HAVE EVAPORATED IN
SOME CASES.
TROOPS SAY THEY FOUND TRAITORS
HERE BUT LACK EVIDENCE TO
PROSECUTE, CITING ONE CASE.
AND NOW, A LOCAL ON THE PHONE IS
REASON FOR SUSPICION.
RUSSIAN TROOPS CAME TO ONE MAN'S
HOME, SAYS AN OFFER TO MAKE HIM
A LOCAL LEADER IS NOT SO SIMPLE.
HE WAS A LOCAL MAYOR FOR THEM.
THAT'S WHY THEY NEVER TOUCHED
HIM AND ALSO A FORMER RUSSIAN
COLONEL LIVING HERE.
THEY SAY THEY HAVE REASON TO
KNOW THEY'RE BEING WATCHED.
I'LL ONLY SAY THAT WHEN WE FIRST
CAME HERE, HE SAYS, IT WAS IN
THE MORNING WHEN THERE WAS A FOG
AND IT WAS IMPOSSIBLE TO SEE US,
BUT THE RUSSIANS SHOT AT US
WHICH MEANS SOMEONE GAVE US UP.
AS WE EMERGE, A PUFF OF SMOKE IN
THE SKY, EXPLOSIVE OR A FLARE.
TWO BLASTS, LEADING THEM TO
THINK THAT CLUSTER BOMBS MAY
FOLLOW AGAIN.
VLADIMIR STAYS IN PLACE, THE
BACK AND FORTH PERSISTS.
FOR PLACES THAT CEASE TO EXIST
IN THE FIGHT FORWARD.
>> AND NICK JOINS ME NOW FROM
KHARKIV, ANOTHER CITY WHERE
UKRAINIAN FORCES APPEAR TO BE
MAKING GAINS.
INCREDIBLE TO WATCH THAT FOOTAGE
AND JUST TO SEE WHAT YOU'RE
WATCHING FROM NOW, RUSSIAN
FORCES SEEM TO BE MOVING BACK IN
SOME PLACES.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE
REASONS WHY?
>> YEAH, IT'S UNCLEAR EXACTLY
WHY UKRAINIAN FORCES ARE HAVING,
IT SEEMS, SUCH SUCCESS AROUND
WHERE I'M STANDING HERE IN
KHARKIV.
YOU CAN HEAR A DOESN'T RUMBLE OF
ARTILLERY OVER THERE AND THAT'S
ALSO WHERE THEY SAY EVIDENCE
POINTS TO HOW THEY RECLAIMED A
NUMBER OF VILLAGES RECLAIMED
FIVE, 10, MILES AWAY FROM WHERE
I'M STANDING AND APPEARS TO BE
MINIMAL RUSSIAN RESISTANCE TO
THAT AND REPORTS WE CAN'T
CONFIRM THEY'VE RUSHED 500
TROOPS FROM AREAS UP TO HERE FOR
BOTH OF THEIR DEFENSES.
SO A LOT MOVING HERE AROUND
KHARKIV, WHICH HAD ORIGINALLY,
HAD THOUGHT WOULD BE ONE OF THE
EASIEST TARGETS WHEN THE WAR
FIRST BEGAN BUT YOU SEE THERE IN
THE SOUTH HOW LITTLE PROGRESS
THEY'RE MAKING AND THIS HAD ALL
BEEN ORIGINALLY PART OF THEIR
RESET FOR THE NEW OFFENSIVE.
THOSE STRIKES IN ODESA, POSSIB